siempre que tenemos una transformación
lineal te lleva de rn nm resulte
interesante estudiar los vectores que no
cambian mucho bajo t en particular los
que son más interesantes son los que no
cambian de dirección cuando les
aplicamos la transformación es decir los
ves tales que te debe es igual a
múltiples escalar del vector original a
un lambda b bien un ejemplo concreto de
esto hace algunos vídeos estábamos
estudiando una transformación de r 2 en
r2 del plano en sí mismo y esta
transformación consistía en reflejar las
cosas con respecto a una recta teníamos
un vector de 1 víctor b 1
quiere el vector
del vector 12
y este vector me genera una recta
simplemente con todos los vectores que
son múltiplos escalares desde 1
genera una recta ahí a esta recta lo voy
a llamar l
así que mi transformación de r2 en r2
consistía en palabras en reflejar
con
respecto
respecto d
a él
bien como se veía esto pues si teníamos
un vector x aquí vamos este entonces la
transformación lo llevaba a su imagen
espejo ponemos que éste su imagen espejo
con respecto de él esto sería de x
simplemente estos dos son simétricos con
respecto a la recta él
y bueno para encontrar la matriz que
representaba esta transformación de r
12m r2 fue muy útil considerar una base
en la que los vectores que la
conformaban no cambiaban mucho bajo la
transformación por ejemplo vimos que si
teníamos a b1 y le aplicamos la
transformación t como de 1
como ve uno está sobre la recta l su
imagen era el mismo de 91 era de uno o
dicho de otro modo
tve-1
es igual a 1 por de 1 así que la
dirección no cambiaba también nos
interesa mucho otro vector
que era un vector perpendicular a la
recta l
nos interesa el vector de 2
que estaba dado por el vector dos menos
uno
y lo que pasaba era que como este vector
era perpendicular a la recta l su imagen
simplemente consistía en pasar lo del
otro lado de la recta r esto sería de
db2
entonces vimos que tv2
menos de 2
lo que es lo mismo
tv2
pero igual a menos 1 por de 2
bien y en esta base no recuerdo cuál era
la matriz de la transformación de hecho
creo que de 2 y de 1 estaban
intercambiados pero obtuvimos una matriz
que representaba esta transformación que
tenía una forma muy sencilla así que era
fácil calcular con ella así que estos
dos vectores fueron vectores
interesantes que satisfacían esta
condición
les doy otro ejemplo supongamos que
tenemos un plano en r3 tengo un plano en
el espacio
que está generado por dos vectores y
considerar la transformación que
consiste en reflejar las cosas ahora con
respecto a este plano un vector que esté
acá arriba lo mando a su imagen
simétrica con respecto a este plano para
ser un vector que está acá abajo bien
entonces una base interesante para esta
transformación sería la compuesta una
base interesante de r3 sería la
conformada por estos dos vectores y el
vector que es ortogonal al plano el
vector normal al plano en ese caso de
nuevo la matriz que representa esta
transformación con esta base de
representada por estos tres vectores
toma una forma muy interesante así que
en realidad lo que nos estamos
interesando en son los vectores vectores
b
que no cambian de dirección digamos este
vector se va a un múltiplo del mismo
quizás se podría invertir el sentido
pero la dirección que da igual no todos
los vectores son así por ejemplo el
vector x se transforma en un vector que
no tiene nada que ver con el vector
original la la dirección cambió
completamente
muy bien y como decía trabajar con estos
vectores que se transforman en vectores
con la misma dirección en múltiplos
escalares del vector original es mucho
más natural las bases son muchísimo más
naturales así que tiene sentido darles
un nombre especial y vamos a decir que b
es un
vector propio doctor propio
l
vector propio de t
irlanda
blanda va a ser un
lambda es un
valor propio
flor propio
de d
bien por ejemplo en este caso de 1
v 1 que es el vector 1 2
vector propio de tema
producción
dt donde t es la reflexión con respecto
de él con valor propio valor propio
y del mismo modo
b2 b2 dado por el vector
2 - 1
es un vector propio del nuevo dt
director propio
con valor propio
un valor propio
en este caso ya no es uno ahora es menos
uno
pero en si es claro que la dirección se
preserva ah pero también nosotros
sabemos que las transformaciones
lineales se pueden representar mediante
el producto con una matriz
a es la matriz que representa a la
transformación t así que si tengo un
vector propio dt
se debe pues por un lado significa que
tiene la forma planta de pero también lo
puede escribir como
por el vector b así que en este caso en
este caso os digo que
ven
vector propio
todo el propio
de a
y que lambda lambda de nuevo
es un valor propio
propio de b
y de hecho en vídeos posteriores vamos a
aprender a calcular esta lambda a partir
de la matriz a pero bueno lo que es muy
importante es que entiendan que los
vectores propios sencillamente son
aquellos que bajo una transformación no
cambian su dirección pueden cambiar de
sentido pueden cambiar de sentido pero
la dirección del vector no cambia así
que esencialmente los vectores propios
son aquellos que no cambian mucho bajo
la transformación t